♪ [ music ] ♪
Tunnel66 is like a way for the MIT community to come together.
We came up with this idea
that would be a really good representation
of the MIT community and be able to connect
us all in isolation.
It's just like a really long vertical tunnel,
online virtual tunnel where MIT students and
MIT affiliates can just draw their own space
and add it to a growing collection of everyone's
spaces, so that it's like we're all quarantining together in the same tunnel.
The hope is that you can like draw either
like a place on campus that you miss, or
a place like your room on campus, or your
current quarantine room
as a way of like bringing all of that together,
like remember and connect with the community.
In general, Borderline tries to give students
at MIT a space and place to create art.
A lot of the murals that we have are AR enabled.
So if you put up your phone to the mural,
you could see an animation playing over it.
And currently, the animations have a little
welcoming message to the 2024s as a way to
kind of bring them into the project.
Tunnel66 let us like the students like the student body
see, oh, wait, there's like this artistic
aspect of MIT, that sometimes people don't
think about as much.
Like the general, public's perception of MIT
is usually like, super technical,
everyone's a hardcore math and science nerd,
but I am really glad that there's an art
community that I hope to join.
All of our rooms are connected by the ladder,
and it just feels like wow, like, although
we're all like a part in all around the world.
Our hearts are a little bit of our heart is
connected by sharing this, whatever we're
thinking or doing with everybody else.
And I like to think that the MIT community
has like one single beating heart.
I would love to have people be able to go
on the site, and feel like they're a part
of something and feel that one beating heart.
And I think that that's the beautiful part
about it is that we're all so different, yet
we all can come together.